ein fleisch das nicht so viel kosten wie
die schachteln zigaretten das ist klar
aber ich finde man muss auch so eine
balance finden wie sie ja auch gerade
sagten zwischen ich beispielsweise ich
habe drei kinder ich kann es mir nicht
leisten für alle beteiligten meiner
familie immer das beste bio zeugs unter
schacht zu stärken
das würde ich sehr gerne aber ich kann
es mir nicht leisten und ich glaube es
geht sehr vielen menschen ich glaube es
gibt menschen auch noch viel schlechter
also gerade wenn die arbeitnehmer denken
an diejenigen die auf diese
werksverträge angewiesen waren für die
es keine lohnfortzahlung gab wir müssen
hier von menschenwürde reden das hat mir
letzte woche gemacht wissen wir wieder
wiederholen
und das ist glaube ich auch die spitze
vom eisberg das was wir gerade sehen
es geht allen fleisch betrieben so
bundesweit in deutschland das ist das
besorgniserregende dass ich sozusagen
dieser bereich und sektor zum
billiglohnsektor entwickelt hat dass es
deutsche gibt in diesen jobs nicht
machen wollen
und anstelle dessen kommen dann
sozusagen auch die arbeitnehmer aus
bulgarien aus rumänien
und das ist natürlich auch in so eine
sehr aufgeheizte stimmung dann trifft
und die tatsache sage ich mal das tennis
der einer der erfolgreichsten
fleischereien in ganz europa ist
bedeutet für mich im umkehrschluss aber
nicht dass es da sondern richtige
[Musik]